en quatre ans donald trump a pris goût à
la vie à la maison blanche
comment s'appelle ce bâtiment
demande-t-il à ses partisans
[Applaudissements]
qu'on pense melania connaît-elle ce mot
de français cleveland lorsqu elle
s'apprête à quitter la maison blanche
après la défaite de son mari le
président grover cleveland il ya 130 ans
je veux que tout soit remis à
l'identique lorsque nous reviendrons
nous revenons dans quatre ans jour pour
jour car grover cleveland un démocrate
est le seul président de l'histoire des
états unis à se faire réélire quatre ans
après sa défaite il est le 22e président
de 1885 et 1889 et le 24e de 1893 et
si donald trump veut rééditer l'exploit
ce ne sera pas facile pour le cuivre à
lui remporté le vote populaire en 1884 à
8,92 il a en fait subi le même sort à
arborer la quintaine récemment c'est à
dire qu'il a perdu une élection tout en
tout en emportant le suffrage populaire
arabe et des situations très différentes
de celles d'autres hommes qui s'il
devait réussir ce qui peut paraître un
peu impensable de revenir en 2024 de
l'emporter l'emporterait
vraisemblablement encore une fois vécu
avec avec une minorité des voix donc
s'offrir sans frais le seul le seul
candidat présidentiel finalement avoir
rapporté deux élections tout en perdant
trois élections ce critère au scrutin
populaire
on
rove le cleveland c'est aussi le seul
président américain célibataire a
célébré son mariage dans le salon bleu
de la maison blanche
il épouse française folsom fille d'amis
proches beaucoup plus jeune que lui qui
sera une des premières dames les plus
populaires des états unis est l'un des
rares présidents avoir accédé à la
maison blanche en étant célibataire
s'est marié au cours de sa présidence
avec une femme qui étaient trente ans
plus jeune que lui
donc effectivement ça c'est quelque
chose qui doit on se souvient ebooks
cleveland était un physique assez
ingrate
d'où son surnom d' ailleurs de hauts
cris en est donc qui le faisait alors
référence à son physique mais également
à sa réputation de probité et son épouse
au contraire effectivement lui a traîné
le gagner beaucoup de capital politique
parce que c'était une femme très réputé
très chaleureuse et très très
charismatique grover cleveland c'est
monsieur anticorruption
il fait le ménage à la mairie de vaux
flou puis comme gouverneur de l'état de
new york et finalement à la présidence
la chose qu'on retient de lui une
réputation d'être extrêmement propre
d'être très honnête et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est particulièrement important
la fin du 19e siècle aux états unis lé
pas qu'on a qu'on a pris le geer de
wegener marquée par une grande
croissance économique mais également par
une très grande corruption à l'intérieur
des machines politiques
malgré un premier mandat très positif il
perd le collège électoral l'élection de
1888 dans son deuxième mandat quatre ans
plus tard il doit faire face à la grande
panique économique de 1893 et à de
nombreuses grèves devenu impopulaire son
parti l'empêchent de briguer la
présidence une troisième fois
sur son lit de mort en 1908 les derniers
mots de cleveland sont j'essayais
tellement fort de bien faire d'autres
présidents des faits ont tenté de se
faire réélire en vain martin van buuren
en 1848
milov fils mort en 1856 plus récemment
d'autres prises dans des faits robben
trouvait en 1932
jimmy carter en 1984 et george bush père
en 1992
ils y ont pensé mais ont renoncé à se
représenter
- départ
jean michel laurens radio canada
montréal